did you guys like the new Drake album he
got some good songs on there it's not
bad it's different feel I is it
different is different different like
how bro like what Dr likes to do he
likes to do the same thing over and over
I no
[__] what
about G he don't do that my son he gets
on different Beast you know what I like
I really liked I really liked when he
did the the EDM album cuz at least you
tried something new bro this album was
something new is you really listening
yeah I listen to the whole album I mean
I think you really listen to a game I
did sh with him Savage is the best track
I love the song with jcole that [__] is
fire I love the song with sexy red and
scissor to surprised me I ain't going to
lie I jacked that song you going to head
that sh in the clubs would you say you
jacked it yeah I jacked it what's that
mean it means I [__] with it some New
York Ling okay I just got to make sure
yeah I'm just letting you know cuz you
know where I'm from if we say we jacked
something we either stole it or you know
it's like I I I got jacked off you know
oh
right
no so you guys uh you guys have been
going crazy uh since the last time you
were here obviously y'all were going
crazy last time you were here but now
y'all got a song going crazy on the
radio how's it feel like get in the car
and turn turn the [__] on and your
shit's playing does it feel good not
every time I see it I start smiling like
a Walky
feeling radio yeah what's Walky mean
please put me up on your guyses bro yeah
like that's a crazy walk drip okay so if
like y'all are Walky right now with the
drip walk is like drink bro n not even
bro no I know walk is like like like
actual lean right yeah yeah that's Walky
but and feel me his son is crazy like
wow that's Walky that's wild that [__] W
yeah it can mean good it can mean
bad so it's like got m multiple
applications basically like your
sprite's real Walky or yo you look at
Dum Walky right now yeah you could say
somebody look walk if but for me it
could be good Walky or bad Walky what
about a Jabba Walky what do y'all think
about them what the [__] is a jabu walk
they're dancers they're Asians oh the
[__] might be wearing a mask yes yo
them [__] nice where my dad what's a
jabu Walky bro the [__] the real
walkies the the real walks bro wearing
the mask bro mask N I got to see that
you know them I don't bro I about aren't
there walkies in Star Wars there's
walkies in Star Wars I I ain't watch
Star Wars you guys have never seen Star
Wars Star Wars was for for the weirdos
growing up what the [__] does that mean
where the [__] did y'all watch as kid
Star Wars Star Wars is for the School
shooters bro what Star Wars is for
School shooters enate Star Wars is for
the schol Jen are you cosigning the
school shooter Star Wars
correlation was for the weird too yeah I
was never watching I only watched one
anime bro and that [__] was dead fire I
used to watch a little bit of Dragon
Ball Z but that [__] was like me Dragon
Ball Z was acceptable yeah acceptable
all these are the chocks you've never
seen them a you mean mes they dance bro
they dance bro they're like [__] sick
ass dancers they got they got a Vegas
show [__] is nice bro
yo moms they were jacking for
sure what
what
I'm hey man I'm just trying to I'm just
trying to you know I'm just trying to
see what they're I'm trying to you know
get down with the Brownsville lingo my
apologies that was bad Jes I guess I
[__] missed that one by a th000 miles
got no Star Wars you guys ever watch
Lord of the Rings
oh what the star Boy watch that I us
commercial Harry Potter Harry Potter I
tried to watch Harry Potter har Potter
like it like I could have grabbed like
you ever watch Percy Jackson per oh the
um that was kind of like Harry Potter
and [__] huh I know what you talking
about I watch that [__] but Harry Potter
with the gods right like all those type
of shows for the serial killers Bro
[__] you got to chill bro I guess I'm a
cal [__] Used to Be Wild what's
y'all's favorite Disney movie oh um let
us Sean G I don't even know what that
isan it I'm sorry what says the guys who
ain't never seen [__] Star Wars
judging me you want know Let it Shine
Google that [__] what the [__] is a Let
It Shine the with the rap [__] yes what
you talking about Roxy I'm
sorry about that yeah I like to oh this
okay what y''s favorite hey bro Classic
this I what is what's y'all's favorite
cartoon Disney movie yeah this is a live
action is the guy St definely Toy
Story's fire Disney pix Pixar
Disney fire too which one the real one
St was fire cerella was fire Cinderella
huh yeah nice I like cars Princess and
the the frog is amazing what cars is
fire you guys ever watch record
Ralph my favorite movie my favorite
movie bro that's that [__]
Rel why you why do you relate toal cuz
he's like he's misunderstood big on
Disney which one big big yeah yeah that
was on Disney solid very underrated
movie watch that is tough you guys ever
watch w-e Wally was myit what that to
make me cry they
Val fire and it's so good cuz it's got
no it's really no talking in it it's
just like w it's like the [__] and the
[__] robot and the dude robot you know
and they like you know sh what's the
what's the name Eva Eve is it Eve or Eva
I forgot I think it was Eva yeah great
movie I watch Wally we gotta go to the
movies today bro y'all horing some new
movie dad just came out is there a new
movie I don't know mad new [__] just
came out I just watched uh what's the
last movie I saw I don't even know the
exorcism came out I heard that show was
mad scary yeah you didn't see the OG one
I don't really like scary movies N I
feel you you like you guys like scary
movies I do what do you like what what's
your favorite uh insidious insidious
that's a yeah the last Insidious yo the
last condrin that they dropped was wild
scary too I feel like scary you don't
like scary movies Jen n i don't I
wouldn't watch it on my own I I've never
watched a scary movie on my own can you
turn your mic towards your mouth P yeah
I never yeah I don't really watch scary
movies on my own bro we group out in
cool I do scary movies what about saw yo
we about to go watch
yesterday they just dropped a new one
they brought the dude back the dude died
a million [__] times and somehow he's
[__] back again I don't get it it's
[__] crazy you guys while you're out
here you guys need to go to Halloween
Horror Nights at Universal Studios
Halloween yo we supposed to go there
last night bro no the [__] was telling
me to go there I was fight BR [__]
guys chasing you around out we out y'all
be horsing [__] don't want to listen
wait what does that mean if someone's
horsing nigg you just snotted all over
the mic don't get that [__] don't get
that was a that was a lot of [__] he
said I see it it's hanging on the mic
cord I'm holy
yo son just went crazy on with the the
booger just flew yo sh look like Anyway
[__] just went viral feel me nah we a
go viral what's h mean I want to see on
the internet what I hor mean like mean
like like for me like you like uh mean
you horse him bro h horing mean like
like if you're [__] a [__] or you
horing l oh LLY gaging okay see you're
speaking on white gu you're [__]
Lolly gagging bro [__] Lolly gagging
with me you're [__] Lolly gagging bro
[__]
[__] G ganger what is it Gangster I put
ganger at the end all
my it's like a period basically it's
like but like it can start a sentence
too ganga has mad meaning I mean I'm
aware that one I'm pretty hip to you
know I'm not a [__] I'm not a total
weenie you know I'm saying like in New
York we say yeah I think they say
Gangsta a lot everywhere all the time
but wait we're not calling somebody
ganga we're just saying gangster is
there anything Brownsville specific
y'all say that's only like people would
only know if they're from your area
Brooklyn it's a lot of
[__] NY grew too
much I ain't going to lie that's some
new [__]
though what some Spanish [__] I mean
it's really like some Spanglish [__]
nice